two minutes of opening credits that do
nothing for nobody
Ricardo montalbán how could I possibly
sit through this movie and not make like
a thousand and one fantasy island jokes
and yeah I know he was in that one
episode of Star Trek that one time
waiting also what about in the 23rd
century what about it huh what about it
starship enterprise on training mission
to gamma Hydra movie drops enterprise
name into the Kobayashi Maru test pretty
much only to try and trick the viewing
audience into thinking this opening
sequence is real and not the Kobayashi
Maru G's Spock Hurra bones and Sulu
could the movie be trying any harder to
make me think this isn't a Starfleet
Academy test also are we really to
believe these three super senior
officers are spending their time
play-acting as jr. bridge officers for
the sake of college students stand up
nice dramatic turn entrance but what the
are you doing just now facing the
science officers ass
in other words dramatic turn for the
sake of dramatic turn is traumatic turn
course closing don't worry it's those
exact same Klingons in the exact same
formation from the exact same shot in
the first Star Trek movie V drew will
take care this is a simulation right why
would you put something that dangerous
in a simulation or is Sulu really that
great of an actor and now we find out
it's a simulation none of what we saw
matter still this fake action is better
than the first movie which i think is
still going on what about my performance
your performance it's sooloos that was
the best in the scenario and looks like
he pulled off another amazing feat by
disappearing from the scene altogether
Admiral wouldn't it be huh George Takei
mmm Kirk collects old revolvers and old
ships what marvelous character
development by set design also that
telescope is clearly pointed at the
apartment of some promiscuous
green-skinned aliens losing is there any
doubt oh now we get the curved fireplace
wall of helmets am i hiding from i'm
yourself Admiral
hiding from your shelf cliche we are
continuing our search for a lifeless
planet to satisfy the requirement of a
test site for the Genesis experiment so
far no success the universe of this
movie suggests it's really hard to find
planets with no life futuristic
communication displays will have
terrible horizontal hole if they get
this guy off a scrap heap from the Blue
Lagoon auditions
see it because this is a movie we've
beamed you down roughly several thousand
yards from a maybe possible life form
thing space Breaking and Entering yeah
we're definitely positive this place has
oxygen so let's remove our helmets
instantly science this asshole has two
copies of Paradise Lost and one copy of
the Holy Bible we've been standing here
in a sandstorm waiting for you to come
outside just for this traumatic moment
starship reliant to captain Tyrell wait
that dude was the captain and he went on
a weak team mission with one other dude
how many Starfleet regulations two -
break we'll be unintentionally inspires
kylo Ren ah okay fine
maybe they briefed you on the existence
of the sky khon but you were in the
episode space seed of which this movie
is a continuation you were even in that
season and then this asshole Kon
pretends like he knows you about buying
a checkoff khaki
Carrick was your host he repaid his
hospitality by trying to steal his ship
and murder him thanks expositional check
out oh no that worm was about to go
inside that ear-shaped plate oh I see
the crew is still taking smaller ships
and shuttles to the enterprise and
they're still parking her in sections
easy at Disneyland in the last movie the
transporter was on the fritz and it made
some sense they had to take some
shuttles here but now that all is normal
can't they just beam to this thing
second Star Trek movie felt like the
first Star Trek movie didn't slumber
over the enterprise enough so adds more
slobbering I had a weave no sir but dr.
McCoy pulled me through bleep outta luck
surely that is this movie saying Scotty
has gonorrhea burst training voyage mr.
president yes sir well see to it that
you don't die tragically have you ever
pilot or distortion by the space dock
never sir
well it's easy you just tell Sulu to
pilot out take her out mr. Saavik in the
future we will be calling women mistress
despite Star Trek being one of the most
socially inclusive properties of all
time I mean why not just refer to her
ranking No you might be tempted to think
this guy down here is waving goodbye to
the fleet's flagship but really he's
just trying to get their attention to
tell them they left a coffee cup on top
of the ship before taking off his
efforts were in vain and the $6 coffee
was lost forever
forget it are you wearing your hair
differently it's still regulation
Admiral it is isn't regulation that may
I speak sir this logic driven nervous
rookie Vulcan stops the turbolift before
even asking if she can speak freely
based on this tion alone how am I to
know if I'm on the fourth or fifth floor
I feel like I'm on the 4.5 floor just
based on the signs this futuristic
science station is composed of 40% light
brights is it cool that this mirror is a
mirror that also has airport landing
strip lights inside it yes yes it is is
it in any way practical well
I can't see how it possibly could be
practical so know where they only ship
in the quadrant as always the enterprise
is the only ship in the quadrant they
should have named the enterprise the
serendipity spot these cadets of yours
how good are they how they respond under
real pressure well they're cadets so so
much the Lu trading foods was that what
this was was the newly minted Admiral
Kirk doing on a little training cruise
thank god he's a micromanager huh he
tests me and I shall have him now I can
see why that copy of Moby Dick was
haphazardly tossed on the top of all
that Divine Comedy we saw earlier so
that Khan could completely ignore the
message of that book well I've got sick
bay ready now will someone please tell
me what's going on if you don't know
what's going on then what do you have
sick bay ready for exactly identify for
retina scan Kirk Admiral James tea
processing you're obviously completely
different expression from the previous
shot Admiral how much money did they
spend on this high production value
video about a super-secret thing no
one's supposed to know about how many
graphic effects artists had a sign NDA's
just to get this thing made matter is
reorganized with life generating results
and despite this lifeless moon or
planet's distance from Sun it will be
able to maintain that life for some
reason it's one of ours Admiral it's
reliant okay so Kirk doesn't know that
Khan and crew are free and in control of
reliant sure but a quick microsecond
computer search will reveal reliant is
the Federation ship assigned a regular
one the Space Station Kirk got a
personal emergency message from so you
know once in four no individual or
computer on the ship running a basic
Google search for the Reliant at this
point the movie is still running with
shields down which is amazing because
you'd think that something like hijack
ships were just common enough that the
enterprise would be cautious in a
situation like this for a ship that
doesn't have the shields up the
enterprise takes these phasers like a
champ you think the series of explosions
in this sector would lead to devastation
but you'd be wrong they knew exactly
where it is except where the weapons are
but what are the chances the enterprise
gets a chance to shoot those up
have we pointed out how amazingly
crazy-ass lucky Khan is yet check off
just happens to land on his Exile planet
thinking it was a completely different
planet on a mission involving project
Genesis something that can both create
and destroy all life on a planet and it
mentioned perfect for megalomaniacs he
wants revenge on Kirk who also just
happens to be tagging along on a
training mission when everything goes
down and he comes to the scene
gift-wrapped for a revenge plot I defied
your shape of pout and when I swing
around I mean to deprive you of your
life but I wanted you to know first who
it was who had beaten you okay fair
enough he wants to rub it in but why did
he shoot that photon torpedo with the
bridge a minute ago that was his plan
but easily could have killed Kirk you
hand over to me all data and material
regarding the project called Genesis why
does he need that from Kirk doesn't the
rely on have the same information the
enterprise does surely before he left he
tried to get as much info from check off
and Terrell that he could right this is
some bull Kirk and by the time necessary
to escape admin oh it's coming through
now calm
Connors kind of a stupid fucking idiot
to fall for this stalling tactic
counter-attack No well phasers on target
and now with my command
phasers look awesome but a minute ago
when rely at Lock phasers on you prior
to firing you could tell lock faces and
tying locking phasers on target they're
walking failures so what gets you in
time let's find out how badly we've been
hurt screenwriter timing allows for this
tragic real-life answer to Kirks
rhetorical question also can you think
of any reason the chief engineer would
leave the engine room carrying a dead
body and show up on the bridge like this
Kirk tours the overflowing emergency
room of his own making which good for
him facing his demons tending to his
flock but it's kind of downright
unbelievable not one of these injured or
maimed patients calls Kirk out for one
Tinley ignoring the call to raise
shields at a time that would have
avoided all this carnage not one boo or
anything you still work give an admiral
the word is given um what what word what
does this exchange mean you're allowed
to die kid who is it your post Scotty
while you cry over one dead trainee of
many who's fixing the goddamn ship and
doing their duty right now huh
yeah what engine room reports auxiliary
power restored
we can proceed at impulse power and the
trainees down there in the engine room
did it all without the help of seasoned
veteran Scotty who was in King sickbay
crying over a dead kit also didn't they
lose their main power before and they
just now restored auxiliary power how do
they do all that they did to the Reliant
with the existing power they had hey
we're beaming to a science station that
might be held by enemy forces let's go
with the winter you know
shall we somehow despite all logic and
Starfleet regulations this away team
includes the captain the chief doctor
and a brand new recruit with no
experience making it the least logical
away team in the history of Star Trek
what is this an even more ridiculous rat
than the one that shows up in a vent at
CIA headquarters and mission impossible
or did Scorsese possibly direct this
character accidentally bumps into dead
appendages cliche now I know where
Jurassic Park got it this movie must
have blood for super bright red paint
hmm what creeps in not a bud keys to
control out of mine and he's hoping
you'll forget how stupid it would be for
him to take them out before you got here
so that he can trick you again and make
it down here was not my impression spent
most of his time trying to wring the
information out of the people con
apparently tried to extract information
from everybody on this base but somehow
didn't scour the area looking for a
place like this which would have told
him everything you know it's been left
on which means nobody remained to turn
it off because as we all know Star Trek
transporter rooms are turned to the off
switch
after every successful transportation
Admiral if we go by the book like
lieutenant Saavik look Khan is a super
genius okay the fact that he doesn't
realize he's being tricked right here is
insane hey lieutenant setec don't bother
scanning for life forms down here or
anything that's not important at all by
the book indeed I mean sorry had a nap
mind control slugs apparently leave
enough the original brain behind to
allow for apologies like this I guess no
TV
son of a bitch well as long as the
characters unimportant I'm okay with a
sex identity
a little connect and the absolutely
totally mind controlled guys suddenly
have a hard time following orders
Starfleet captain who was mind-control
to this point somehow overcomes his mind
control which sounds awesome until I
tell you who only overcame it long
enough to commit suicide and why does
the other mind-control worm want to
escape all the sudden did it feel its
twin get murdered now it needs to mourn
dude at least let it crawl away from
check off for a few seconds before
obliterating it Jesus
paranal I come also dude you're tricking
him about the time the enterprise needs
to heal remember why are you so upset at
this apparent radio wind icon is this
method acting who is con hi there a
person who obviously didn't watch the TV
show or the first hour of this movie
let me exposition you to death how can
you think of food at a time like this
first how could you not think of food
right now dude humans be hungry oh if
you're not hungry you might be an alien
controlled by the ear slugs
why didn't you tell how can you ask me
that is this really some baby mama drama
in a Star Trek movie skip Genesis is not
conflicted with the production designer
about whether there's such a thing as
too many waterfalls start to spot two
hours are you ready right on schedule
Admiral wait you spoke in code earlier
because they could intercept your
transmissions but now you're what
speaking in anti code awesome Kirk a
smart moment absolutely ruined by the
inconsistent logic movie suggests you
can carry out conversations during
transportation there inoperative lo C
deck what is we're here on not much
Admiral we have partial main power aa
partial main power that explains nothing
sauce for the goose mr. Saavik the odds
will be even okay walk with purpose now
with purpose do these greats all need to
be lifted up before a torpedo can fire
because if so that's stupid and why is
the torpedo loading bays super huge and
open to human beings shouldn't this be a
contained unit on either side of the
home this is the dumbest torpedo
protocol ever
also if torpedoes take this long to load
and launch the Federation is doomed man
Jesus Christ did they do all this book
every time they launch a torpedo cuz
haven't I seen Kirk order someone to
fire the torpedoes plural before imagine
all these below deck performers having
to do all this double-time reliant is
closing I will give you the time before
we hit the nebula but I will not give
you any kind of time data on the ship
trailing us that wants to kill us that I
shall leave babe they just almost going
in there David pops onto the bridge
seconds after the ship rattling warning
shot from reliant during which we were
treated to a shot of David not anywhere
near the bridge down below with the
doctor his mother and laughing at the
superior intellect Conn Falls for this
raise the shield as I feared sir not
functional why is the nebula selective
about what can and can't work inside of
it I get the monitoring systems going
out even the shields
why not a whole bunch of other systems
like the ability to fly the ship
enterprise Luck's out and ends up
directly behind the reliance somehow I
mean Jesus there are no shields up this
ship has been hit a million times at
this point it's on auxilary power does
it take to kill it I've got to take the
mains off the line I have no idea what
any of this means the power the ship
uses and runs out of is completely
random whatever nonsense to make the
movie more dramatic and this particular
plot development will lead the Spock
making a dramatic sacrifice until he
appears in the next movie he's
intelligent but not experienced this
pattern indicates two-dimensional
thinking he's not intelligent spawn he's
a genetically engineered superhuman
who's inexperienced with starship battle
should not prevent him from thinking
three dimensionally funny how these two
ships lost in a gas cloud continued to
find each other at the last minute on
the static field monitor these guys are
playing battleship but with flashes of
the opponent's board before they take a
shot
how is everybody dead on the bridge
except calm yeah he's got superior
physical ability but not against Oh
explosions right I can't stop giggling
at this engineering dude back here from
the looks of it just has a bad headache
but he'll if he's going to intervene in
the situation or even notice it engine
room
what's happening and he waited a long
time before calling down there a second
time Spock was still on the bridge the
last time he called engineering why
aren't their radiation suits for exactly
this kind of occurrence I think you're
better get down here you need to take a
look at this cliche Spock this is a room
you get killed for going in you go in
here like when you're a technician at a
Starbase and the ship is in for an
overhaul and the radioactive engine has
been shut down for a while but sure
let's put an intercom in there just in
case we ever need that Shannon out of
danger gotta admit Spock's sacrifice is
one of the most badass moments of
badassery ever bad asked and we will
remove five sins for we are assembled
here today to pay final respects to our
honored dead he's dead now but only if
this movie is an absolute total failure
you know what brings people back from
the dead straight cash homie this was
the most human goddamn this scene gets
me every time
two sends off for real emotions in the
Star Trek movie why are they torpedoing
Spock out onto the Genesis planet I mean
thank God they do but that's not the
point
do Vulcans not have burial rituals sir
cemeteries um and that's exactly what
walks through the door very proud to be
your son
then james t kirk and his son had many
many adventures after this movie he's
really not done
as long as we remember it and we write
screenplays with Spock in them we really
really really don't want you to actually
think we killed Spock setting alpha six
exploded six months after we were left
I'm your doctor and I'm your friend I'm
a politician which means I'm a cheat and
a liar and when I'm not kissing babies
I'm stealing their lollipops hey dad is
it alien planet is there air you don't
know my dear guests I am mr. Roe welcome
fantasy I
bleh
the light is I'm tonight
I guess we'll be going down together I
mean getting off to get I mean that's
okay I'll just push the button for the
stimulator
I mean elevators I'd middle feet gosh
darn it I give up
it's yours you can have it you have to
give me a minute to put it in a box for
you each of whom what did you just say
on the test sir how do you do it Frank
would you pass the baton Louisiana he's
intelligent but not experienced this
pattern indicates two-dimensional
thinking you're just not thinking four
dimensionally